منذ ايام تمكنت مديريه امن محافظه
القليوبيه في مصر من اعاده طفل يدعى احمد
الشامي بعد تغيب عن اسرته لمده اربعه ايام
الشامي تم اختطفه على يد مجهول استدرجه من
احد محلات الالعاب الالكترونيه بجوار
منزله مرتكب الواقعه اوهم الطفل البالغ من
العمر سبع سنوات بانه سيفتح له حسابا على
لعبه ببجي واصطحبه بعيدا وطبعا بعد
استغاثه الاسره وفحص كاميرات المراقبه
بمحيط المنطقه نجحت اجهزه الامن في تحديد
هويه الجاني وضبطه قبل ان تعيد الطفل
لاسرته للحديث اكثر عن الواقعه سوف نستضيف
الطفل واسرته من مركز الخانكه بمحافظه
القليوبيه
[موسيقى]
الموبايل والانترنت هو سلاح جو حدين بمعنى
ان في دار وفي نافع بالنسبه للدار هو مدر
الاول بالعين ثانيا الجلوس على الانترنت
اكتر من نصف ساعه او ساعه ده بيضر العين
ونبضات القلب انا عندي مبدا في حياتي ان
انا اولادي قاعدين على النت كل شويه اجي
ابص وهم بيعملوا ايه وبعدين ما بخليهمش
يطولوا قوي في ابلكيشن بستخدمه بس اعرف
المواقع اللي دخل فيه ابني او بنتي دخلت
فيه انما اللعبه زاد نفسها مش هتقدر تعمل
فيها غير انك انت لما تمسكها وتجربها مره
واثنين وثلاثه
لو انا ماسك التليفون 24 ساعه اكيد الطفل
هيحس ان دي حاجه
مهمه جدا ابويا بيستخدمها ووديتها
مستخدمها
هينجذب ليها وهيبدا يستخدمها زيه زي والده
زي امه خليه يبقى عنده مسؤوليه لاي حاجه
يعني اشغله من باب ان انا اشغله بس كده دي
في حد ذاته بيفرق
[موسيقى]
والله بتعرفي عادل الحمد لله على وسائل
التقنيه الحديثه مثل الكاميرات المراقبه
وغيره يعني مكنتنا من انه نحل الغاز مثل
لغز اختفاء الطفل واعادته لاهله المشكله
انه هذه الالعاب ببجي وغيرها وكان قبلها
الحوت الازرق الى اخره تبرر الاطفال رغم
الدراسات
والنصائح المتواليه انه حذر اولادكم من
استخدام العاب العنف الى اخره اليوم هذه
طبعا راح نتحدث عن كل هذه الموضوعات راح
يكون معنا طبعا الاب وطفله الذي اختطف بعد
قليل باذن الله القاهره نذهب وينضم الينا
من هناك والد الطفل المتغيب
واللي عثروا عليه طبعا الوالد محمد الشامي
استاذ محمد
الحمد لله على سلامه ابنك وبالتالي سؤال
الابرز
كيف حدث ذلك ايه اللي حصل ازاي مين الراجل
ده
طيب الحمد لله طبعا على سلامته يعني سلامه
ابنك استاذ محمد وعلى انه رجع يعني الحمد
لله كله صحته تمام وكل شيء تمام محمد قديش
يعني ما بعرف بهذا الزمن اللي احنا فيه
هل تعتقد بانه في مسؤوليه نوعا ما على
الاهل بانهم على الاقل يتحدثوا مع اولادهم
يفهموا الاولاد انه مش المفروض تتحدثوا مع
اي شخص غريب واكيد مش المفروض انكم تذهبوا
مع اي شخص غريب حتى لو قال لكم راح اعطيكم
حلويات او اعمل لكم اي
حساب على لعبتكم المفضله هل كان في لك
حديث مع ابنك بهذا الاطار قبل هاي الحادثه
اه انا كنت كل يوم بقول له الكلام ده كنت
كل يوم بقول له ما تمشيش مع حد ما تاخذش
حاجه من حد وبرضه الاهالي برده كان
المفروض تعمل كده
ولكن على ما يبدو براءه الاطفال بتخليهم
انه يصدقوا اي شخص بيجي بقول لهم بدي اعمل
بدي اخذكم على مكان جميل او او اعطيكم
حلويات وممكن انهم يذهبوا معه
هو المفروض اي طفل ما يمشيش وراه اي حد
واعمل ابني مشي مش وراه على اساس اللي هو
هيجيب له ايميل ببجي ومش ايميل ببجي وضحك
عليه طبعا وخدوه وقعد اربع ايام
وجبناها من القليوب الحمد لله طيب يعني
ايه اللي ازاي فقدتوه يعني بعد اربع ايام
حتى عاد
ما هي ما هي ظروف عمليه الاختطاف قالوا
لكم ايه الداخليه
قالوا لنا اللي احنا هندور على الواد
وهنجيبه ان شاء الله مش هنكمل يومين ان
شاء الله هنجيبه وقعدوا طبعا يراجعوا
الكاميرات في في ابو زعبل وفي الخانكه وفي
جميع جميع الخطوات
قال ايه المتهم
اللي خطف
المهتم طبعا
يعني معترف اللي هو خاطف الولد ومش بس انا
بطلب بطلب اللي هو ياخذ اعدام عشان ما
يعملهاش ما حدش يعملها ثاني
طيب يعني لاحظت الحمد لله انه يعني ابنك
بصحه جيده جنبك هل تحدثت انت وياه الولد
هل اعطاك يعني قال اي قصص حول كيف وين وين
اخذوا كيف قضى هذول الايام هل كان يطعميه
مثلا ام لا
هو طبعا يعني هو قعد به ليلتين في على
محطه قليوب طبعا الواد كان متبهدل برده من
قله الاكل والكلام ده بس الحمد لله رجع لي
بالسلامه يعني
بس لازم اسالك نفسيه احمد عامله ايه اتغير
ازاي بعد الاربعه ايام دي
هو الصراحه يعني هو انا بحاول انا اشيل
الموقف ده خالص هو مستوعب الحاجه دي انه
اتخطف اربعه ايام